[Música]
pero explicar que yo hace en abril del
2017 que hace dos años va a ser dos años
salí después de 30 años de carrera en
agencias de publicidad que son las
estructuras muy determinadas y después
de 21 años en la agencia que yo
contribuye a fundar y que llevaba una de
mis letras sc pf la ansiedad se agarra
los hace dos años salí para ser lo que
yo llamo freelance es verdad que
técnicamente seguramente no soy un
freelance somos cuatro personas es para
que sea autónomo no tenemos oficinas no
queremos tener oficina cuando yo me
considero un freelance
la cuestión es que yo puede intentar
explicarlo en diez minutos por qué razón
se nos ocurrió se me ocurrió o tuve la
necesidad de convertirlo en final desde
un punto vista metafórico yo yo tenía la
sensación no tuve la sensación durante
muchos años de mi vida durante 30 años
de mi vida de estar en un sitio
maravilloso en una atracción como una
noria por ejemplo
en la que me lo pasé muy bien estaba muy
divertido pero durante los años que
íbamos a de los años iba subiendo cada
vez que subía arriba la noria iba viendo
que en el espacio alrededor de la noria
iban apareciendo otras atracciones
y al final habían muchas otras cada vez
que bajaba en la noria preguntaba o
vieran los clientes o bien a mis socios
que eran una multinacional inglesa la
mayor parte del tiempo de w pp si podía
ir a mirar oa trabajar o hacer las cosas
que hacían
esas otras atracciones a mirar aunque
fuese y me decía no nos sigue en la
noria que la noria sigue dando dinero y
está bien y además
la tracción y el número de de maravillas
que había predominado sitios y que ya
casi insoportable y decidí salir un poco
esto sería una explicación metafórica
explicación más técnica sería
en 1990 el año siguiente el gran premio
que ganamos en cannes que en el medio
digamos del dominio de la televisión
como el único medio o el gran medio de
la publicidad ésta era la única
categoría que existía en el festival de
cannes en cannes se premiaban spots
además que se consideraba que la
publicidad eran los spots todo lo demás
que se obtuviera su publicidad o no era
publicidad o era descartable
llega internet esto explota en mil
pedazos y en 2009 es decir hace diez
años
ya hay todas estas categorías y las
categorías sean duplicados o triplicados
decir
film era una de estas y de pronto
aparecen directo ciber publicidad
relaciones públicas disciplinas que
existían algunas nuevas algunas ya
existían pero que de pronto adquieren
una relevancia que nunca habían tenido
por poner un ejemplo no sé si aquí hay
muchos directores de marketing pero no
saben de lo que hablo de marketing hoy
se tiene que enfrentar más o menos a
ésta
cantidad de canales en los que comunicar
la marca y lo que la marca quiere decir
los frutos que
solo este fragmento de aquí que poner
digital que es una pequeña parte de todo
lo que aparentemente una parte de lo que
sería esto
en esto se ha convertido básicamente la
publicidad en un
en una enorme fragmentación de que de
aquella gente a la que le tenemos que
hablar antes la gente vosotros estabais
como aquí la televisión o los medios
masivos era un lugar al que no llegaba
contaba su cosa y prácticamente todo el
mundo escuchaba
funcionará con bastante eficacia y hoy
todos hoy estáis aquí pero luego
estaréis en distintos canales cada vez
más que además desconocidos e incluso en
canales que vosotros mismos
podéis organizar cuando digamos lo que
ha ocurrido es que hemos pasado de una
audiencia cautiva y masiva a una
audiencia fragmentada
pues simplificar mucho
lo que ha ocurrido esto yo antes
trabajaba en una agencia de publicidad
que se dedicaba a hacer spots pero claro
nuestra la dimensión de lo que nosotros
hacíamos era tan importante que al final
ocupaba nos ocupamos todo el espacio
la agencia de publicidad se hacía por
televisión se confundía con la
publicidad era el spot de televisión a
un sinónimo de la publicidad
todavía hoy ocurre un poco eso cuando
hay técnicas la publicidad hace anuncios
televisión bueno entre otras cosas
entonces ser así es así gracias al uso
de televisión no estaba trabajando en
publicidad entonces que ocurría es que
la idea o el concepto o la marca llegaba
con bastante consistencia y con bastante
integridad al consumidor final uno tenía
una idea la lanzaba en televisión y esa
idea llegaba
coherencia notable hoy lo que ocurre más
o menos es decir tú tienes una idea un
concepto un territorio que la marca
quiere ocupar ese territorio esa idea se
tiene que contar en todos los canales
distintos aquí podrían haber muchos más
canales y lo que suele llegar al final
es una rotura una fragmentación de esa
idea original lo que suele llegar al
final es la marca disgregada rota
fragmentada
entonces visto esto he visto qué
yo como profesional siempre he pensado
que lo que digamos que él acabará
haciendo es por televisión nada más que
un accidente porque lo que yo de verdad
hacía era pensar en conceptos y
estrategias para marcas decir yo lo que
siempre ha querido pensar y siempre he
podido trabajar sin hacerlo es eso de
allá arriba he decidido que si no salgo
de la agencia de policía es decir si no
salgo de uno de estos franjitas de
colores no se me va a contemplar como
alguien que es capaz de hacerlo de
arriba y esa es la razón fundamental por
la que he colocado como freelance o como
gente libre en medio de este espacio de
complejidad un poco por utilizar un
eslogan lo que a lo que quiero dedicarme
ahora que soy freelance no es tanto a
tener una estructura que crea idea es
decir
yo antes trabajaba en una carpintería y
hacíamos cosas de madera
aquí están
7 de vidrios de ventanas y cosas de
vídeo lo que hoy hace falta es tener
ideas que ellas mismas generen la
estructura que vaya a construir al final
el producir hoy hoy yo lo que sé hacer
con un arquitecto o yo siempre me
consideran arquitecto pero siempre
trabajado entre la carpintería hoy
quiero ser un arquitecto que trabaja con
cualquier estructura que me permita
contar aquello aquello que la idea es de
la manera más adecuada posibilidad lo
que la idea es para eso os voy a contar
tres o cuatro cosas que me parecen
fundamentales la primera hoy me ha
pasado por ejemplo hemos ido presentar a
un cliente siempre que vamos a presentar
un cliente nos dice bueno tengo un lío
hoy cada vez más tal como ha visto con
la complejidad con la fermentación que
además los clientes hay un toque se
encuentran las marcas en mente que se
encuentran que han empezado a hacer
cosas antes para comunicar
y cuando se ponen a poner encima de la
mesa lo que han hecho se da cuenta que
es un lío llaman y dicen creo que creo
que tengo un lío y podrías un poco
ordenar las cosas y te preguntan cuánto
que cuanta información quieres que te dé
yo siempre digo ninguna
de momento lo que gustaría es ver yo por
mi cuenta cómo está marca es percibida
por un consumidor normal como yo y yo
desde mi experiencia desde mi intuición
como comunicador te voy a decir desde mi
ignorancia te voy a decir lo que creo
que la gente percibe leyendo a
al no bajar y el grupo que es un libro
que conocéis bien esta magnífica
historia del mapa de salviati 1525 que
es el primer mapa o por lo menos el
primer mapa conocido que se atreve a
eliminar de la cartografía digamos las
invenciones las imaginaciones con las
que se rellenaban los espacios vacíos
que se colocaban dragones se colocaban
lo que fuese cualquier cosa menos que
hubiese un espacio vacío por el espacio
nacido generaba pánico de pronto hay un
tipo que decirnos si no sabemos lo que
hay no sabemos lo que hay y te vamos a
poner lo que hay y genera mapas así que
construyen una
unas ganas de ir a ver que hay ahí donde
no hay nada que generan de pronto la
ansiedad por conocerlo
el conocimiento científico moderno
procede del reconocimiento de que no
sabemos nada o de que sabemos poco pues
la manera digamos de luchar contra ese
predominio de la especialidad que hemos
visto antes cuando hemos visto que había
en todas esas casillas
todas esas casillas que son casillas de
empresas especialistas el especialista
se caracteriza o nos caracterizamos
porque también soy especialista por la
pretensión de saber de qué hablamos por
la pretensión de tener el dominio de una
parcela determinada de saber una parcela
determinada de conocimiento o de técnica
de un especialista
se representa como alguien que sabe de
lo que habla yo lo que quiero recuperar
es todo lo contrario me gustaría que se
me contemplase como alguien que sabe
comunicar pero que no tiene ni idea de
qué son las marcas tienen personas
marcas porque solamente en ese proceso
entre lo que no sé y lo que pueda
aprender que es una marca es cuando yo
puedo aconsejar correctamente una marca
lo que tiene que hacerlo ferran hace
muchos años cuando cuando empieza a
tener fama atrae a los mejores alumnos
de las mejores escuelas de todo el mundo
de hostelería y me decía llegar aquí
llegar con chaval matrícula honor cum
laude de la mejor escuela superioridad
de suiza y aquí me dices señor se range
es que tengo que hacer y entonces él les
decía coge de esta piña y la cortas en
los trozos más delgadito sin más finos
que se puede ocurrir cortar y el pobre
chaval que su padre le ha regalado por
fin de carrera un estuche con los
cuchillos vas a antes del mundo
japonés y tal se va una esquina de la
cocina y empieza a cortar a cortar horas
ya cada uno ahora consigue una loncha
maravillosamente fina de piña entonces
va a cerrar
se aferran serenamente cortados que se
que finales y el fraile dice
y podríamos hacer esto
porque ferrán llega a la conclusión de
que es mejor esto porque no tiene idea
porque no tiene prejuicios no tiene no
ha pensado previamente nadie le ha
contado previamente lo que tiene que
hacer no ha sido un especialista si no
ha sido un hombre que previamente ha
tenido que pensar en que se podía hacer
mejor y al llegar a la conclusión o por
ejemplo para saltear era mejor social
con esto de que una cucharadita o por
ejemplo son güells hace hace de
ciudadano kane como lo hace porque no
tiene idea que el cine no es así
no sabía que había que construir de
hecho dice que construyan techos porque
él quiere poner la cámara bajo no es que
la cámara se puede poner abajo y cayó
que se va que éstas tienen texto lo voy
a leer que es maravilloso
hablando de hablando de la mediocridad
dice en el mundo animal siempre hay que
nos aventaja en algún aspecto el águila
con su agudeza visual un mirlo con su
paleta de millones de colores un búho
con su visión nocturna un oso polar con
su olfato de largo alcance un zorro del
desierto con su sensibilidad auditiva la
anguila con los campos eléctricos
ciertas bacterias con los campos
magnéticos especialistas sin embargo
nadie supera nuestra sublime mediocridad
del conjunto de todos los sentidos
cruzados mediocridad esto es lo que es
un ser humano producto ignorancia por
encima de todo producto hay que regresar
al producto
el principal emisor de comunicación de
cualquier marca es el producto porque lo
hemos olvidado porque la tele hizo que
el producto no tuviera importancia la
tele era tan eficaz tan poderosa que
cualquier producto se vendía hasta el
punto de que las marcas blancas surgen
cuando hay televisión es decir una marca
comete el error de venderles un producto
al distribuidor al caprabo al campo o al
medio mercadona de turno su propio
producto vendido más barato
piensa que la tele va a justificar esa
diferencia obviamente con el tiempo la
gente descubre que los frutos son
iguales que es más barato del
supermercado y comprar eso eso es porque
hemos olvidado que el producto era lo
importante la publicidad es un impuesto
que hay que pagar por no tener un
producto memorable lo primero que hay
que hacer hoy para hablar de
comunicación es echar el producto quién
quien nos escribió que es un producto
magistralmente jobs cuando le preguntan
quién diseñó el producto el mch
wozniacki dice noam wozniak diseñó este
que es una cosa extraordinaria
maravillosa pero que no es un producto
porque el producto es aquello que
construimos para que se comunique con la
gente decir si no hay un si el producto
no contiene en sí mismo los elementos de
comunicación que hacen que sea
comprensible por la gente no es un
producto es cualquier otra cosa es un
invento
joe convierte aquello en esto y con esto
está diciendo a quien voy que quiero ser
para qué sirve qué ambición tengo la
diferencia entre anterior y este es la
diferencia de comunicación esto es
comunicación o por ejemplo cuando jobs
vuelve de next y crea el arma que lo
hace transparente y le pone un as a
alguien utilizó alguna vez este asa
o sea es un anuncio que se está diciendo
creo en un ordenador transportable creo
en un ordenador ligero creo en un
ordenador que se mueve no tienes que
dejar en la mesa no es un cacharro para
la mesa este asa es el ipad es el iphone
de ustedes yo como veo la informática es
así es un anuncio no es en realidad un
argumento real como producto
y como conclusión esta frase de john
berger que creo que tiene que ver con
con él con todo es decir estamos en una
época en que hacemos cosas o probamos
cosas o nos equivocamos mucho o no
avanzaremos mi padre colocó encima de la
chimenea de casa este árbol para que no
se nos quedará grabado y es justamente
esto hacer
[Aplausos]